- Alexandre Poussart: Bonjour.
Bienvenue dans "Parlement hebdo".
On revient
sur les temps forts
de la semaine au Parlement.
- Kathia Gilder:
Nous accueillons Laure Lavalette,
députée Rassemblement
National du Var.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Un nouveau 49.3
à l'Assemblée nationale.
Elisabeth Borne
dégaine cette arme
pour passer en force,
avant même
qu'il y ait un débat
dans l'hémicycle.
Le drame de l'assassinat
de Dominique Bernard pose
une question:
avons-nous tiré les leçons
de l'assassinat
de Samuel Paty
il y a 3 ans?
Plusieurs voix
s'élèvent pour durcir
le projet de loi immigration.
Le ministre de l'Intérieur
Gérald Darmanin
est ouvert
à des modifications du texte.
- Kathia Gilder:
Le débat budgétaire
a été écourté
à l'Assemblée nationale.
Elisabeth Borne a eu
recours au 49.3
pour faire passer
la partie recettes
du budget sans ouvrir
le débat au parlement.
Voici le compte rendu de séance.
- Il n'y
avait aucun suspense
quand la Première
ministre est arrivée
à l'Assemblée ce mercredi.
- Aucun groupe
d'opposition n'est prêt
à voter ce projet
de loi de finances.
Notre pays a besoin de ce budget.
Sur le fondement
de l'article 49.3,
j'engage la responsabilité
de mon gouvernement.
- Un 49.3 utilisé
à 13 reprises,
et cette fois,
en coupant court au débat.
- Le gouvernement
innove même en matière
de 49.3.
On n'avait jamais
déclenché de 49.3
sur un budget avant même
d'avoir commencé l'examen
des articles.
- Même si on avait débattu,
les oppositions
nous auraient dit
que ça ne servait
à rien.
On a clarifié la situation.
- Dans ce budget,
le gouvernement prévoit
de ramener le déficit
à 4,4% du PIB.
Dans sa copie finale,
le gouvernement
a retenu l'extension
du prêt à taux zéro,
le maintien
du dispositif Coluche
pour la défiscalisation des dons.
En revanche, pas de taxe
exceptionnelle
ou de crédit d'impôt
pour les résidents
en EHPAD.
- Kathia Gilder:
Tous les groupes d'oppositions
avaient dit
qu'ils ne voteraient
pas ce budget en tant que tel.
Elisabeth Borne
avait-elle le choix?
N'avez-vous pas aussi
votre part
de responsabilité dans ce blocage?
-
Laure Lavalette:
Nous n'avons pas la même
vision
de la France que ce gouvernement.
Nous n'aurions
vraisemblablement
pas voté ce budget.
Néanmoins, arriver
à faire un 49.3
sans même faire
semblant d'écouter
les oppositions,
c'est quand même fort.
On en est au treizième 49.3.
D'habitude,
ils faisaient semblant
de nous écouter.
Le fil rouge
de ce gouvernement,
je l'ai vécu
toute la semaine dernière
quand j'étais en commission
des Affaires sociales,
c'est qu'ils agissent
un peu
comme une secte.
Ils ne prennent
même pas les amendements
qui pourraient émaner d'autres
groupes politiques,
même pas 1%.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Le gouvernement
a pourtant retenu
300 amendements
qui émanaient
notamment de la part
de l'opposition.
- Laure Lavalette:
La France a changé.
La majorité a perdu
beaucoup de sièges
lors des dernières
élections législatives.
Ils vont rechercher ceux qui sont
"Macron-compatibles".
Nous étions très attachés
à ce que la fiscalité
qui pesait sur la France,
la France
qui travaille, migre un peu
sur la fiscalité
des grands groupes
et des multinationales.
Pour la troisième
fois consécutive,
ils n'ont pas voulu
voter la taxation
des superprofits.
C'est dommage.
Nous avons tous
la même légitimité,
nous avons tous été
élus en France.
Arriver à balayer
d'un revers de main
cette diversité
politique,
ça ne me semble pas
être la façon
de faire.
Je pense que c'est sectaire.
Sur les marchés,
c'est ce que les gens
nous disent.
- Kathia Gilder:
Le fait de recourir aussi souvent
et aussi franchement
au 49.3,
est-ce que ça fragilise
Elisabeth Borne
et son gouvernement?
- Laure Lavalette:
Ils sont fragilisés
depuis longtemps,
juste après la deuxième élection
d'Emmanuel Macron.
On a vu
qu'ils n'avaient pas de majorité.
Il y a un désavoeu
des Français
pour ce gouvernement.
Emmanuel Macron
nous avait déjà habitués
à de la brutalité.
Il y avait eu des mots très forts.
"Emmerder les Français"...
Je pense que ce gouvernement
a une certaine surdité.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Pourquoi les députés
du Rassemblement National
étaient opposés
à ce budget qui prévoyait 16
milliards d'euros d'économies?
- Laure Lavalette:
Ils ne font pas d'économies
structurelles.
Sans cela, ils finissent
par rehausser
les impôts.
On ne peut pas se satisfaire
de cela.
Il y a des économies à faire.
On n'a pas vu d'économie
dans le projet proposé
par le gouvernement.
On a des points
de désaccords
qui sont très marquants,
notamment
sur l'Europe.
Les oppositions
ne votent pas le budget.
- Kathia Gilder:
Vous auriez souhaité
qu'ils retirent
des amendements,
notamment
ceux qui permettent de taxer
les multinationales?
- Laure Lavalette: Bien sûr.
Ca fait 3 ans
que l'Etat refuse
de le faire.
C'est un très mauvais
signal envoyé
aux Français qui souffrent.
Les Français vivent
une crise sociale
sans précédent.
Dans la circonscription,
j'ai encore rencontré
des Français
qui me disaient
ne pas dîner le soir.
Ce n'est pas la société
dans laquelle
on veut faire vivre les Français.
Il y a de véritables
économies à faire.
Le gouvernement
n'en a pas pris le chemin.
Il continue à faire
des cadeaux
aux grandes multinationales.
- Kathia Gilder:
L'actualité a percuté l'ordre
du jour à l'Assemblée.
Après l'effroi, les questions.
Il y a eu pas moins de 10
questions
sur l'attentat du lycée
dans l'hémicycle
de l'Assemblée.
Trois ans après l'assassinat
de Samuel Paty,
les groupes ont interpellé
le gouvernement
sur le sujet.
- Pourquoi ne pas étendre
les expulsions
à ceux qui ont commis
des crimes
et des délits graves
à leur sortie
de prison?
Islamistes, criminels
et délinquants:
qu'est-ce qui justifie
de garder
ces personnes sur notre sol?
- Vous vous lancez
dans les politiques politiciennes.
Vous multipliez
les mises en cause.
Alors que le terrorisme
frappe
et que la situation
internationale
est préoccupante,
vous refusez explicitement l'unité
de notre pays.
- Kathia Gilder:
Plus d'unité nationale
après cet attentat d'Arras?
- Laure Lavalette:
Je suis navrée
de la réponse d'Elisabeth Borne.
Elle n'a pas du tout répondu
aux questions
de Marine Le Pen.
Sur ma circonscription,
lundi, j'étais
à l'hommage
de Samuel Paty
alors que Dominique
Bernard n'était
même pas enterré.
C'était inconcevable.
Il aurait dû
y avoir un avant et un
après Samuel Paty.
Comment on a laissé faire ça?
Comment ça a pu arriver?
La soeur de Samuel
Paty nous dit
que son frère est mort pour rien.
On n'a tiré aucune leçon
de la décapitation
de Samuel Paty.
Cela fait 3 ans.
Il est temps
d'avoir des actes forts.
On a un projet de loi
qui est ficelé.
Marine Le Pen l'avait proposé
au dernier mandat
sur la lutte
des idéologies islamistes.
Il faut expulser
les fichés S étrangers,
mais il faut surtout lutter
contre l'idéologie islamiste.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Quand Marine
Le Pen critique
le gouvernement seulement
quelques jours après la mort
de Dominique Bernard,
est-ce que c'est de la
récupération politique?
- Laure Lavalette:
Nous sommes élus
par les Français
pour protéger les Français.
Comment faire
union nationale
avec ceux d'en face
qui n'arrivent
même pas à condamner
le Hamas
comme "organisation terroriste"?
Je ne peux pas faire
une union nationale
avec Mathilde Panot, par exemple.
Les Français attendent
des décisions
qui les protègent.
J'ai rencontré lundi un couple
de septuagénaires
trop mignons
qui m'ont arrêtée
dans la rue
pour me dire
qu'ils avaient acheté
une bombe lacrymogène.
Je n'ai pas envie
que des grands-parents vivent
comme ça!
C'est au gouvernement
de protéger
les Français.
- Kathia Gilder:
Emmanuel Macron dit
que dans un Etat
de droit,
on ne peut pas totalement
éradiquer
le risque terroriste.
Si vous étiez au pouvoir,
vous pourriez l'éradiquer?
- Laure Lavalette:
Le président
de la République
est censé protéger
les Français
et il vous dit
qu'on ne peut pas le faire.
Bien sûr qu'on peut le faire!
Ce gouvernement
n'a pas la volonté politique
de faire différemment.
Gérald Darmanin avait dit
qu'il allait fermer
les mosquées salafistes.
On en est où?
A chaque fois qu'une
mosquée a été fermée,
elle a été rouverte
quelque mois
plus tard.
On nous dit
que les fichiers du FSPRT
vont être passés au peigne fin.
On ne comprend pas
que ça
ne soit pas déjà le cas.
Quand on marche
dans la rue, on se dit
que les gens qui nous veulent
du mal peuvent
nous croiser.
J'ai conscience qu'un
travail a été fait.
Les politiques
et les gendarmes travaillent
dans des conditions
très difficiles,
mais ils font leur travail.
A côté de ça,
si on ne met pas en prison
ceux qui veulent
porter atteinte
à notre intégrité nationale...
Pour ça, il faut des prisons.
C'est encore une promesse non
tenue d'Emmanuel Macron.
Il n'y a pas cette volonté.
Il faut une fermeté
et une judiciarisation
de tout ce qui tourne
autour de ces idéologies
islamistes.
Ca remonte à longtemps.
Les Républicains
sont aussi fautifs.
Un rapport de 2004 parlait
de la pénétration
de l'idéologie
islamiste à l'école.
Il avait été mis sous le tapis
par François Fillon.
Ce rapport alertait
déjà en disant
que certains
enfants
ne voulaient pas entrer
dans certaines salles
de classe
parce qu'il y avait du rouge
et que c'est haram.
Cela fait longtemps
que le Rassemblement National
parle de ce sujet
et rien n'est fait.
- Kathia Gilder:
Gérald Darmanin assure
que son projet de loi immigration
faciliterait l'expulsion
des étrangers dangereux.
Il dit que cette loi aurait permis
d'éviter l'attentat d'Arras.
- Laure Lavalette:
Ce qui aurait évité l'attentat
d'Arras,
c'est que ces personnes
ne soient pas sur notre sol.
Gérald Darmanin
a le taux d'OQTF
le plus bas de l'histoire.
Il devrait faire appliquer la loi.
Les lois européennes
vont obliger
la France à répartir
les migrants dans les campagnes.
Il faut protéger les Français.
On ne peut pas donner
un peu d'un côté
et ouvrir tout de l'autre côté.
Après la Belgique,
Gérald Darmanin
a dit qu'on allait
renforcer les contrôles
à la frontière.
Ca veut quand même dire
que ce concept désuet
de frontière pourrait
avoir son intérêt.
En France, on a déjà
de quoi protéger
les Français.
Ce qui manque,
c'est la volonté politique.
- Alexandre Poussart:
On va parler
de cette loi immigration
qui sera discutée
au Sénat début novembre.
Les sénateurs veulent
durcir le projet
de loi
du gouvernement
mais ils ont
quelques désaccords
avec les centristes.
- Le texte immigration:
un casse-tête
pour Gérald
Darmanin avant même
son examen au Parlement.
Le ministre
sait
qu'il ne pourra pas
compter
sur les LR
dont il a besoin
pour avoir une majorité
s'il
ne recycle pas l'article
3 qui prévoit
de régulariser
les sans-papiers
dans les métiers en tension.
- Ce sont des lignes
rouges sur lesquelles
nous ne lâcherons pas.
- Une ligne rouge
à droite qui agace
les centristes.
- Il est important
pour un seul article.
Il faut trouver une solution.
Après ce qui s'est
passé à Arras
et Bruxelles,
quand on voit la difficulté
au Proche-Orient,
s'arrêter sur un article
comme celui-là,
ce n'est pas au niveau
de la situation.
- Trouver un accord pourrait
vouloir dire sortir
la mesure du texte,
mais le groupe Renaissance
à l'Assemblée refuse
cette situation.
- Il faut juger
les étrangers
pour ce qu'ils font
et non pas
pour ce qu'ils sont.
- Sans point de convergence,
le ministre cherche
à séduire autrement les LR.
- S'il y a des propositions
supplémentaires
qui permettront,
à n'importe quel moment,
et conformément
à ce que le gouvernement essaye
de faire, c'est-à-dire
avoir la fermeté
contre tous
ceux qui veulent toucher
aux valeurs françaises,
je donnerais
un avis favorable.
- Pas sûr que les efforts
de Gérald Darmanin suffisent.
Les 7 et 12
décembre prochains,
les oppositions feront
d'autres propositions.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Les sénateurs
Les Républicains veulent
durcir ce projet
de loi immigration
pour lever
encore plus de freins
aux décisions d'expulsion.
Gérald Darmanin y est favorable.
Comment les députés
RN pourraient-ils
ne pas voter ce texte?
- Laure Lavalette:
Gérald Darmanin
est dans une position
difficile au sein
de sa majorité.
Certains collègues
de Gérald Darmanin disent
qu'ils ne peuvent pas voter
ce texte.
D'autres députés
sont pour la régularisation
des clandestins.
Vous voyez à quel point
c'est difficile.
Nous, nous pensons
que ce texte
ne va pas assez loin.
Cette dichotomie
entre ce qui va venir
chez nous et ce qui va se faire
au niveau européen,
c'est le vrai problème.
On n'arrive pas en France
comme ça.
Il y a des droits
et il y a des devoirs.
On n'est pas sur la même
longueur d'onde
avec Gérald Darmanin.
Il dit qu'il veut
durcir,
mais ça fait 6 ans
qu'ils sont au pouvoir.
Pourquoi
n'ont-ils pas durci avant?
Pourquoi est-ce que tous
ces gens-là
étaient sur notre sol
alors qu'ils n'auraient
pas dû?
- Kathia Gilder:
Il y a un volet fermeté
dont vous parlez,
mais il y a aussi
le fameux article 3
qui permet de régulariser
dans les métiers en tension.
- Laure Lavalette:
Retirer cet article,
ça ne va pas assez loin.
Cet article 3, c'est une nouvelle
filière d'immigration
pour la main-d'oeuvre,
notamment
dans les métiers
en tension
comme la restauration.
Il faudrait plutôt
augmenter les salaires.
C'est une nouvelle
filière d'immigration
alors que nous n'en pouvons
déjà plus.
Ce gouvernement a des records
en matière d'immigration légale.
Les Français
ont compris le lien
entre cette immigration
et l'insécurité.
75% des mineurs
qui sont déférés
au parquet de Paris
sont des mineurs étrangers.
Ce n'est pas possible
de les garder
sur notre sol.
Gérald Darmanin
aurait déjà pu faire
en sorte
que ça ne soit pas le cas.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Si ce texte
est durci, s'il n'y
a plus cet article 3
et si les freins
aux décisions d'expulsion
sont levés, est-ce que le RN
pourrait voter
ce texte?
- Laure Lavalette:
On va attendre
de voir
comme on l'a fait
sur tous les textes,
mais en matière d'immigration,
ça n'ira pas assez loin.
Il faut reprendre
la maîtrise
de nos flux migratoires
au niveau national.
Ca reste chapeauté
par l'Europe, donc
tout ce qu'on pourra
faire en bas,
ça ne changera rien.
Marine Le Pen avait proposé
un référendum
de 17 pages au moment
de la présidentielle.
Elle voulait proposer
un référendum expliquant
qu'il fallait
que les Français aient
la maîtrise de leur flux
migratoire.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Le RN a effectivement proposé
un texte.
Ce sera débattu
en décembre au Sénat.
- Laure Lavalette:
On va voir
comment ça va arriver.
Pendant l'entre-deux tours,
Les Républicains disaient
qu'on ne pouvait pas faire ça.
Ils vont pourtant
proposer quasiment
la même chose
que ce que proposait
Marine Le Pen.
Les Républicains
ne voulaient pas mettre fin
au droit du sol.
Ca nous paraît
pourtant fondamental.
Ce n'est pas
parce que vous restez
en France que vous êtes français.
Il faut vouloir adhérer
aux valeurs françaises.
Le droit du sol,
enfin l'absence
du droit du sol
pourrait nous empêcher
de voter ce texte.
- Kathia Gilder:
Quand on a des preuves,
des écoutes avant même
la condamnation
en justice, il faudrait
pouvoir expulser
les étrangers?
- Laure Lavalette: Bien sûr.
On ne peut pas garder
sur notre sol
des gens qui sont des bombes
humaines.
Quand vous avez
une personne
qui est sur notre sol
et fichée
pour radicalisation...
Ca nous permettrait
de protéger le peuple.
On demande aux dirigeants
de retrouver
une certaine sécurité.
Quand on a des preuves
tangibles
qu'il y a une
radicalisation,
qu'il y a une apologie
du terrorisme,
par exemple...
Avec les réseaux
sociaux, on arrive
à retracer le profil des gens.
Il faut protéger les Français.
Il faut expulser tous
ceux qui veulent porter atteinte
à notre pays.
On ne peut plus...
Il y a eu le Bataclan,
il y a une Nice...
Les Français ont voulu
fêter le 14 juillet,
et 80 d'entre
eux ont été écrasés
par un radicalisé.
Ce n'est pas la société
dans laquelle
je veux vivre.
- Alexandre Poussart:
On parlait
de 49.3 sur le budget.
En cas d'utilisation
du 49.3
sur la loi immigration
de Gérald Darmanin,
vous pensez qu'une censure
pourrait faire tomber
ce texte?
- Laure Lavalette:
Ce serait
encore une fois d'une
brutalité inouïe.
Ca voudrait dire
qu'on ne discute
plus de rien.
Depuis qu'on est élus,
on nous dit
que le texte
immigration va arriver
sur la table.
Ca fait déjà un an et demi
et il n'arrive jamais.
On voit
que la majorité
n'est pas à l'aise.
- Kathia Gilder:
La présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale
souhaite
un vote avant la fin de l'année.
- Laure Lavalette: Il y a urgence.
Notre famille
politique alerte
depuis longtemps
sur l'idéologie islamiste
et ses ravages dans notre pays.
Il faut prendre
la mesure
de ce qu'il y a à faire.
Je ne suis pas sûre
que le gouvernement
soit le mieux placé.
Quand on voit le bilan
de Gérald Darmanin
dans une démocratie
ordinaire, il aurait
peut-être déjà démissionné.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Une partie
des terroristes
qui ont frappé
notre pays sont étrangers.
Mais est-ce que cela
signifie
pour vous qu'une majorité
des étrangers représentent
une menace pour notre pays?
- Laure Lavalette: Rien à voir.
C'est au cas par cas.
Tous les étrangers
ne sont pas terroristes,
heureusement.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Alors pourquoi vouloir autant
limiter l'immigration?
- Laure Lavalette:
Quand vous avez 10 millions
de pauvres et 6
millions de chômeurs,
vous vous dites
qu'il y a déjà suffisamment
de monde sur votre sol.
Vous devez vous occuper
du peuple français
en priorité.
Il y a le problème des salaires.
Au Rassemblement National,
nous voulons augmenter
de 10% les salaires
avec une exonération
des charges.
Il faut rendre
le travail attractif.
Dans la mandature
précédente,
il y a eu un rapport
qui a été
fait par les collègues
députés,
où ils parlaient
de l'insécurité
qui montait
quand il y avait des MNA,
mineurs non-accompagnés,
sur le territoire.
Il y a un lien évident
entre l'insécurité
et l'immigration.
Il est temps de régler
ce problème.
Si vous avez des enfants,
vous devez
le vivre au quotidien.
Ce n'est plus tolérable.
Les Français n'en veulent plus.
- Alexandre Poussart:
On finit
par une polémique
qui concerne
votre famille politique.
Votre collègue
Laurent Jacobelli a été filmé
en train d'insulter
le député Renaissance
de Moselle, Belkhir Belhaddad.
"Il va bien, le Hamas?"
Il a dit cela.
Laurent Jacobelli
l'a traité de racaille.
- Laure Lavalette:
Vous prenez
un tout petit bout d'une vidéo.
Laurent Jacobelli
ne s'est pas pointé
en lui disant ça.
Il y a eu un échange houleux.
C'est d'une malhonnêteté
intellectuelle
de montrer seulement
cet extrait
de la vidéo.
Ca a été une tentative
de diversion.
Laurent Jacobelli
est un formidable député.
Il travaille beaucoup.
Il est d'une gentillesse
connue de tous.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Donc traiter
son collègue de "racaille",
c'est normal?
- Laure Lavalette:
Il faudrait regarder l'extrait
en entier.
- Kathia Gilder:
Merci, Laure Lavalette,
d'avoir été notre invitée.
On se retrouve
la semaine prochaine.
SOUS-TITRAGE LIVE: RED BEE MEDIA